im lehrmethoden feuerwerk oder
lehrmethoden monokultur was ist
eigentlich besser weil gibts sowas
überhaupt was sagen kann dass es besser
ist wieviel lehrmethoden innerhalb von
einer der veranstaltung hätte man auch
formulieren können ja und das passt
deswegen wunderbar zu meinen beiden
vorredner rinnen die er jetzt einfach
mal methoden vorgestellt haben sie
systematisch eingeordnet haben das was
ich sehr überzeugend fand und jetzt
müsste man aber natürlich fragen wie
viele wände ich denn jetzt davon 91
minuten veranstaltung mache ich jetzt
aus jedem quadranten eine mache ich aus
jedem quadranten 2 habe ich nur zwei
prozent pro pro 90 minuten das ist im
prinzip die frage und ich möchte mal
ganz vorne anfangen und zwar hat mich
das nämlich eigentlich genau genommen
wenn man genau zurückschaut ging das mit
mir mit der pädagogik und
erziehungswissenschaft letztlich schon
damals los
das war mein erster schultag da ich in
der schweiz dann die eingeschult wurde
hatte ich keine schultüte auf diesem
bild die habe ich nämlich dann erst zu
hause wieder gekriegt was ich aber in
der schulzeit eigentlich erlebt habe war
eine wesentliche monokultur also das
hieß eigentlich im wesentlichen haben
wir frontalunterricht gehabt wir saßen
in reihen ich habe gestern als ich das
bild noch gescannt habe tatsächlich auch
gesucht oder gefunden zufällig noch
bilder wo wir tatsächlich auch in reihen
sitzen das ist ganz ganz klassisch
damals sogar noch sehr große klassen
also ich bin tatsächlich schon ein
bisschen alt dann kam aber eben dazu
die monokultur auf der anderen seite
könnte man natürlich dann auch sagen er
macht doch mehr
ja und das ist das was ich auch immer
wieder in meinem hochschuldidaktischen
workshops dann gefragt werden wie viel
soll ich denn machen
und das ging bei mir aber letztlich auch
schon im studium los dadurch dass ich
erziehungswissenschaft studiert habe
habe ich relativ viele bekannte gehabt
die nicht wie ich jetzt jungs geschafft
auf magister studiert haben also schon
von vornherein gesagt haben die schule
möchte ich eigentlich nicht sondern die
natürlich lehramt gemacht haben die
mittlerweile gymnasiallehrer und so
weiter sind die aber dann oft mehr
unterrichts vorwürfe vorgelegt haben
wenn sie wieder unterrichtsbesuche
hatten und so weiter und da war dann zum
teil das reinste feuerwerk zwei minuten
murmel phase drei minuten vortrag drei
minuten mindmap und den tanks zum kotzen
die armen kinder
ja und so geht es letztlich auch für die
schule oder für die hochschule dann auch
irgendwann ist einfach auch zu viel und
deswegen hier die frage im prinzip was
wäre dann das richtige wenn es überhaupt
einen richtigen dem sinne geben kann
schauen wir uns also an das constructive
diamond kann vorher schon mal dran bei
den ersten beiden und dann hat erasmus
es auch sogar noch einmal aufgegriffen
ich habe es hier ein bisschen
dargestellt wir lehren in der
hochschullehre das was die studierenden
lernen sollen und deswegen habe ich das
lernen hier auch dick rot gemacht im
vergleich zu den anderen
das ist nämlich eigentlich das was im
fokus steht es lernen und deswegen haben
sie ja auch oder habt ihr ja auch diesen
titel wahrscheinlich gewählt
studierenden zentriert ja nicht der
fokus hier sondern der fokus liegt
eigentlich da und die studierenden
sollen daneben lernziele erreichen oder
kompetenzen erwerben da möchte ich gar
nicht weiter darauf eingehen das ist
eine eigene debatte kompetenz oder lärm
ziel und dann damit einher geht das
fokussieren die heute aber nicht so sehr
prüfen spielt natürlich dann auch mit
rein
wir sollen dann nämlich eigentlich genau
das prüfen was eben was wir auch gelehrt
haben was die studierenden gelernt habe
und das war denke ich beim vortrag von
herrn cromme super tag hat sich diese
passen wunderbar gezeigt und wir schauen
jetzt also im prinzip an wenn es darum
geht eben lehrmethoden monokultur oder
feuerwerke die leeren damit gelernt wird
also wäre eigentlich letztlich zu
überlegen wenn wir lehren lehre so
lernen auslösen dann müssen die
lehrmethoden janele lärm unterstützung
sein und genau aus dem grund schauen wir
uns ein bisschen an oder möchte ich
gerne ein bisschen vorstellen was
eigentlich lernen heißt was da dahinter
steht und davon abgeleitet dann ein
grundgerüst im prinzip auch vorstellen
wie man sagen könnte so könnte man der
veranstaltung strukturieren und daneben
auch die lehrmethoden dort jeweils
einordnen
lernen was heißt eigentlich überhaupt es
geht letztlich um einen zeitpunkt zu
einem zustand in dem sich die menschen
befinden
zu dem zeitpunkt wo das lernen
gewissermaßen bedingt beginnt wobei man
natürlich sagen kann lernen findet euch
dauerhaft stadt aber wenn wir jetzt an
den startpunkt von einer
lehrveranstaltung denken kann man sagen
okay es gibt irgendwie zeitpunkt da
verfügen unsere studierenden über ein
bestimmtes handlungs potenzial über ein
bestimmtes wissen und dann wird gelernt
und dann haben wir werden wir gesagt
haben es wird gelernt es wurde gelernt
haben wir eine dauerhafte veränderung
von diesem handlungs potenzial oder von
diesem wissen nie was auch immer
ausdrücken wollen
und das findet statt immer durch
erfahrungen durch wahrnehmung durch
beobachtung durch reflexion hätte ich
noch mit aufhängen es verändert sich
etwas beim lernen und das dauerhaft und
wichtig dabei ist es kein international
oder implizit sein also wir schauen im
moment gerade nur aufs lernen ganz
allgemein
ich kann sagen so jetzt setze ich mich
an schreibtisch und lerne dann wäre ich
vollkommen intentional unterwegs und wir
sagen jetzt möchte ich mir irgendwie was
aneignen zum thema der strategien oder
sowas oder lernpsychologie oder wie auch
immer
aber wir lernen natürlich auch implizit
quasi die ganze zeit schon alleine wenn
wir uns miteinander unterhalten wenn wir
jemanden kennenlernen wenn wir an der
bushaltestelle sitzen und irgendwie
situation beobachten darüber nachdenken
auch dann findet lernen natürlich statt
wenn jetzt also wiederum anlehre denken
dann wäre natürlich dass die idee wir
als lehrende versuchen diesen
lernprozess zu unterstützen
schauen wir noch ein bisschen genauer
rein was heißt lernen also in diesem
sinne es heißt eigentlich veränderung
von bestehendem in dem also
gewissermaßen was neues an etwas
bestehendes angeknüpft wird vernetzt
wird damit manchmal ist dieses neue
einfach an knüpfte an das bestehende das
ist das was per se als simulation
bezeichnen was relativ einfach
vergleichsweise noch einfach erfolgt
manchmal ist es aber auch so dass wir
beim lernen mit dingen konfrontiert
werden denken sie da bin ich bisher auch
von anderen dingen ausgegangen
da haben wir also schon zu einem
gewissen themenbereich sozusagen eine
bestehende struktur bestehendes wissen
und jetzt müssen wir um lernen weil das
neue irgendwie nicht passt hier das ist
die akkumulation und das ist natürlich
unglaublich viel schwerer
und auch für uns als lehrende wenn ich
diesen blick immer schon gleich
einnehmen möchte ist es sehr viel
schwerer an akkumulation prozess bei
studierenden auszulösen oder zu
unterstützen als eine assimilation
prozess weil es bedeutet hier müssen
verbindungen gekappt werden
gewissermaßen da müssen neue
verbindungen aufgebaut werden die vorher
als für unmöglich gehalten wurden und so
weiter und in diesem sinne kann man
sagen lernen und das ist jetzt sozusagen
der einer der gültigen lern begriffe aus
der lernforschung kann man sagen lernen
ist ein aktiver konstruktiver prozess
denn es findet immer eine erweiterung
oder eine veränderung von bestehenden
stadt und dieses veränderte das
veränderte handlungs potenzial das
veränderte wissen das muss auch weil sie
dauerhaft gespeichert sein soll oder
dauerhaft verfügbar sein soll auch
gefestigt werden kurzer blick vielleicht
noch mal zurück ich habe das hier
versucht so ein bisschen schematisch wie
es auch in der kommission psychologie
manchmal dargestellt wird darzustellen
hier gibt es zwischen diesen idee in
diesen konzepten diesen begriffen von
denen man ausgeht das wissen quasi
gespeichert wird gibt es dünnere
verknüpfungen und dickere die dünneren
sind die die anfällig sind auch quasi
verloren zu gehen
da kommen wir trafen wir lange drüber
nachdenken dann fällt uns auch das noch
dazu ein das was sehr stark gefestigt
ist was wir immer wieder zusammen auf
rufen immer wieder ähnliche handlung
folgen nacheinander ablaufen lassen
da haben wir sozusagen diese autobahnen
dazwischen die firma nicht mehr wie
finden die autobahn findet man ja aber
den trampelpfad durch den wald den
findet man eher weniger und in diesem
sinne also lernen als aktiver
konstruktiver prozess
und in diesem sinne kann man lernen auch
als eine art von handlung verstehen denn
es ist nichts was im prinzip einfach
passiert sondern ist etwas was jeweils
jeder einzelnen lernende aktiv tun muss
es bedarf der aktiven auseinandersetzung
mit lern gegenständen damit wirklich
etwas passiert sozusagen in den
strukturen in der handlung und jetzt
kann man natürlich fragen unter welchen
bedingungen wird denn nun eigentlich
dann gelernt denn das ist jetzt im
prinzip erst mal einfach nur zustimmen
eine beschreibung wie es halt
funktioniert aber wann wird in der
lernprozess eigentlich ausgelöst wann
geht es denn los mit dem lernen warum
sollte jemand eigentlich lernen
da gehen wir es einfach noch ein
bisschen genauer rein und ich möchte so
ein bisschen im prozess aufzeigen und
auch die voraussetzungen die quasi
gegeben sein müssen damit menschen
lernen
im ersten schritt schauen wir uns jetzt
zunächst erstmal nur an wie man das im
prinzip ist also falsch angefangen
wir fahren wie ich möchte gerne
darstellen wie es passiert quasi dann
wenn es mehr oder weniger in wenig
intentional ist mehr implizit dann wenn
einfach wenn ich quasi einfach irgendwas
tun und dabei quasi lerne weil der
nächste schritt ist dann der dass ich
sagen möchte okay wenn es so eigentlich
quasi nebenbei funktioniert ohne große
super anstrengung ja dann können wir ja
als lehrende hingehen und versuchen
diesen lernprozess danach in der form zu
unterstützen so
wir haben also jetzt hier unsere
studentinnen die hat unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten und jetzt muss sie
sozusagen entscheiden in bestimmten
situationen was welchen wert sie denn
was macht sie denn jetzt also welche von
diesen möglichkeiten wählt sie hier
kaffee trinken vorlesungen gehen buch
bücherei gehen sich mit kollegen
auszutauschen was es auch immer sein mag
die welt die möglichkeit die
aufmerksamkeit erzeugt das heißt sie
wird da sich dem zuwenden von den vielen
möglichkeiten die sie hat was ihre
aufmerksamkeit in dem moment auf sich
zieht wenn man sie in die
lehrveranstaltung sieht könnte man sagen
ok sie sitzt jetzt in der
lehrveranstaltung sie ist schon mal
gekommen wenn es der dozent oder
dozenten scharf die aufmerksamkeit auf
sie zu lauf auf aus thema zu lenken
vielleicht in gewissem maße auch auf
sich zu lenken dann wird sie dabei sein
dann hat sozusagen die ihre
aufmerksamkeit gelenkt auf den lern
gegenstand das wäre es ideale gut aber
sie könnte möglicherweise ihren laptop
auf haben
der flop gerade eine e mail auf könnte
auch die aufmerksamkeit erzeugen
es könnte auch sein dass sie aus dem
fenster schaut und irgendetwas
beobachtet was sie total spannend weil
man hört in den baum hoch und darunter
klettert es kann auch sein dass sie auf
etwas aufmerksam geworden ist auf was
sie immer noch nachdenkt was sie quasi
mitgebracht hat in den hörsaal
also es braucht aufmerksamkeit und da
sie wendet sich dem zu was die
aufmerksamkeit quasi erzeugt und
aufmerksamkeit wird immer erzeugt durch
ein sogenanntes mentales ungleichgewicht
das ist der moment wo wir denken so wie
kann das sein was ist hier passiert ja
verstehe ich gerade nicht oder es
irritiert mich ich finde irgendwie
komisch ich habe es bisher anders der
fahren jetzt ist es so oder ist es weckt
auf jeden fall interesse gewissermaßen
ist weg motivation und ich möchte im
prinzip jetzt irgendwie antworten finden
auf das was hier aufmerksamkeit erzeugt
hat oder ich möchte eben in diesem
bereich handeln um irgendwie weiter zu
kommen vorwärts zu kommen
das heißt so ein ungleichgewicht es löst
handeln ganz allgemein aus und bei
wer vorher gesagt haben handeln und
lernen können wir mal irgendwie so ein
bisschen wie wir sagen nein lernen ist
auch eine art von handeln dann kann man
natürlich sagen okay so ein
ungleichgewicht löst es lernen also auch
aus welches handeln wird jetzt ausgelöst
nicht jedes auf jede aufmerksamkeit
jedes ungleichgewicht los gleiches
handeln aus dann gibt es unterschiede
da kommt ganz wichtig die erkenntnisse
auch aus der neurowissenschaften mit
dazu wenn ich negativ ins
ungleichgewicht komme dann hat s max mit
angst zu tun mit negativen emotionen
panik ja und dann sind wir menschen alle
noch darauf gepolt eigentlich die
tendenz zu haben zu fliehen oder zu
kämpfen ja gefahr
wo gott das problem oder was wir alle
mit mittlerweile haben was auch unsere
studierenden haben durch sozialisations
effekte und so weit dass ich rennen
nicht unbedingt aus dem hörsaal raus
wenn sie irgendwie angst haben aber sie
sind in dem moment dann in der angst
situation damit beschäftigt wie kann ich
diese angst situation bereinigen und
nicht wieder in eine solche situation
hinein kommen das heißt dozierende die
manchmal sagen aber manchmal muss man
student auch mal den senkel stellen ja
der löst bei diesem studenten mit
höherer hoher wahrscheinlichkeit sehr
negative emotionen aus aufmerksamkeit
wird ausgelöst ganz klar keine frage der
wird nicht mehr auf den laptop schauen
noch nicht nach dem alter manchen
schauen sondern der wird da sein aber er
wird vermutlich in der situation er den
den reflex der angst oder der der
kampfhund flucht haben wird sich nicht
wie wahrscheinlich der dozent in meinem
beispiel jetzt intendiert hat dem inhalt
plötzlich mehr zu wenden
dafür hat er nämlich gar keine
kapazitäten mehr frei war sondern nur
gucken wie mit komme ich hier wieder
raus so wir möchten ja als dozenten aber
eigentlich eine aufmerksamkeit haben die
sich dann um den inhalt kümmert ja es
geht ja darum wir möchten nicht dass die
angst haben und lernen mit der angst
situation umzugehen sondern möchten dass
sie sich konzentrieren auf den gelernt
gegenstand deswegen ja aktivierende
methoden letztlich auch habt ihr ja
vorher auch vorgestellt und dafür eignet
sich dann eher das und positive
ungleichgewicht positiv in dem sinne
dass es keine direkte bedrohende
angstauslösende situation
es kann die schilderung einer situation
seien zb die aufmerksamkeit erzeugt da
ist immer die medizin ganz gutes
beispiel
ja wenn sie jetzt wenn er unterrichtet
in der medizin und startet eine
vorlesung mit ja was mir mal passiert
ist vor vielen jahren als ich neue
frische assistenzärztin war in der
notaufnahme samstagabend kam der
patienten mit folgenden symptomen
ja und ich wusste gar nicht was ich
machen möchte da habt ihr die
aufmerksamkeit der studentinnen und
studenten in der regel auch weil die
nämlich dann denke ja könnte mir auch
passieren
sie sind aber nicht direkt bedroht es
ist zwar der auslösung von einer
negativen emotionen und emotionen sind
dann der stelle sehr wichtig aber sie
sind nicht direkt bedroht also das würde
helfen
positiv kann man es auch gestalten ich
hab mal was gemacht und es hat super
funktioniert wenn ich das euch erzählen
denkt er vielleicht auch ok konnte ich
vielleicht auch mal probieren
das heißt also dieses positive
ungleichgewicht kann unser kann menschen
dazu bringen sich mit zu beschäftigen
mit gegenständen und dadurch dann im
prinzip auch das lernen denn was
passiert es passiert letztlich das dass
ich wenn ich diesen um
gleichgewichtszustand erlebe als mensch
ich mich sozusagen diesen gegenstand
eben zuwende
und es wird hier dargestellt dass sie
jetzt sozusagen einen lebensraum
betreten hat in dem wie diesen um
gleichgewichtszustand quasi auflösen
will
sie sucht antworten darauf sie sucht auf
ihre fragen antworten und deswegen
durchschreitet sie quasi jetzt bildlich
gesprochen metaphorisch gesprochen
diesen lebensraum hin zu den zielen
und da möchte ich ganz kurz euch ein
kleines bisschen theorie noch noch ein
bisschen mehr theorie zumuten nämlich
die feld theorie die nämlich ganz gut
erklärt waren menschen eigentlich
bereits sind sozusagen motiviert zu
handeln und damit letztlich natürlich
dann auch bereits möglicherweise zu
lernen
hier ist unsere studenten die person die
sich in diesem lebensraum befindet und
sich durch schreie hat den lebensraum
deshalb schon mal betreten weil sie eine
antwort sucht ja eine antwort oder
irgend gleichgewicht wieder auslösen
will deswegen ganz wichtig dieser
lebensraum ist hier nicht im physischen
sinne zu verstehen sondern der hat oft
was mit einer aufgabe zu tun die zu
erledigen ist quasi also dadurch ist er
definiert und auch durch soziales und
was ganz wichtig ist aus dem bereich der
feld theorie dieser lebensraum der wird
wahrgenommen und empfunden und erlebt
und das wird von jedem einzelnen
menschen sehr unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen und erlebt und das ist die
herausforderung die wir natürlich dann
beim leeren wiederum haben weil wir
haben hier nicht einen lebensraum den
wir irgendwie objektiv beschreiben
können außer dir eine physische umwelt
sondern wir haben dann eben 20 30 120
500 studentinnen und studenten je
nachdem wie viele themen sind das heißt
wie ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich auch der
eine wird denken was redet die dann da
sommer zum punkt kommen
andere finden es vielleicht ganz
spannend genauso ist es obwohl wir als
sozusagen physisch gesehen hier
eigentlich alle die gleichen bedingungen
im moment haben wir können jetzt die
temperatur messen wir könnten so eines
licht verhalten das ist so also ganz
ähnlich und es hat was damit zu tun eben
wie interessant findet ihr das jetzt was
ich hier erzähle
wollt ihr antworten finden dann bleibt
er dabei und das ziel zu erreichen soll
jetzt endlich sagen wie viele
lehrmethoden man eigentlich einsetzen
soll oder nicht
oder er sagt auch das interessiert mich
eigentlich nicht dann kann es sein dass
ihr gewissermaßen aus dem feld geht
abschaltet und vielleicht etwas anderes
denkt oder euch dem laptop zuwendet oder
an was wir aus dem fenster schaut ob
doch vielleicht ein eichhörnchen vorbei
läuft dann dieses aus dem feld gehen
hier ist genau die idee die
aufmerksamkeit geht wieder woanders hin
und ich betrete eben nicht unbedingt
gleich physisch aber mindestens vom
denken her einen
unseren lebensraum auf diesem weg um
dieses gleich um gleichgewichtszustand
quasi zu beheben hier muss die hier
durch diese unterschiedlichen regionen
wie levin bis nennt und diese regionen
die haben unterschiedlichen
aufforderungscharakter da man spricht
auch von unterschiedlicher valencia sind
schön ja da ist es humorvoll und nett
und es macht einfach spaß dabei zu sein
und dann gibt es aber auch durststrecken
ja und jeder von uns weisen jedem
studium und in jeder lehrveranstaltung
gibt es auch mal durststrecken und wir
können als lehrende auch gar nichts
dagegen tun wenn wir nur einen studenten
eine studentin hätten könnten was für
sie vielleicht 100 prozent perfekt
machen
selbst das wahrscheinlich nicht aber
sobald wir mehr studierende haben müssen
wir einfach davon ausgehen es wird nicht
jedem zu jedem zeitpunkt immer
gleichermaßen gut gehen und gut gefallen
kann nicht funktionieren
das heißt es gibt regionen mit positiver
valence und regionen mit negativer
bilanz wenn die regionen der negativen
wall enz zu stark werden oder auch so
lange dauern dann geht der mensch aus
dem feld mehr hat dann lässt er sich
ablenken
dann ist plötzlich der laptop
interessant ich war zwar vorher erstmal
als studentin interessiert ja die
dozentin hat hier mal was nettes
angefangen ich war dabei aber irgendwann
denke ich mir was redet sie und sie
redet immer noch und jetzt muss mal was
anderes irgendwie kommen ja es wird
möglicherweise hierzu lagen es wird so
durch strecke und dann lasse ich mich
ablenken und bin raus quasi
wenn die ziele aber stark genug sind
lasse ich mich gegebenenfalls auch
wieder rein ziehen und wir lassen uns
wenn das ziel ganz ganz stark ist auch
nicht von durststrecken abbringen dann
bleiben wir selbst dann dabei und sagen
euer da musste ich jetzt halt
durchbeißen musste jetzt hinten dran
bleiben um das ziel zu erreichen und wir
gehen jetzt eben davon aus unsere
studentinnen hier in unserem beispiel
die hat jetzt ein ungleichgewicht und
das möchte sie ja lösen wie möchte ja
eine antwort finden also bleibt sie
dabei und hoffentlich auch in den
durststrecken dies möglicherweise mal
gibt wann sind alte menschen motiviert
zu lernen dann wenn sie ein ziel haben
ja und dann wird auf die
lehrveranstaltung direkt schon wieder
bisschen dann muss es eine ziel
konkurrenz geben zwischen dem was wir
unterrichten wollen was wir als ziele
als lehrende anstrebt und auf der
anderen sind dem was die auch lernen
wollen wenn das natürlich auseinander
driftet haben ein problem
und dann brauchst die positive valent
das heißt es muss einfach auch irgendwie
nett sein gewissermaßen dabei zu bleiben
zu dröge wird dann kann ich irgendwann
auch mein ziel gewissermaßen mein ziel
wieder in frage stellen und denken so
gut ist es jetzt so wichtig muss ich
gibt es nicht nur alternative kann eine
andere lehrveranstaltungen besuchen zum
beispiel und das lässt sich halt
ansonsten zusammenfassen im prinzip muss
unsere lehrveranstaltungen dann so
gestaltet sein dass sie an den
bedürfnissen der studierenden eigene
bilder vielleicht hätte ich besser
geschrieben individuelle bedürfnisse der
studierenden orientiert ist so weit das
geht und da sehen wir schon bekommen
natürlich als lehrender grenzen weil wir
viele individuen da sitzen haben und sie
nicht zu 100 zu jedem zeitpunkt bedienen
können kann auch nicht unsere aufgabe
sein muss auch nicht unsere aufgabe sein
bin ich der auffassung aber so in die
große richtung zu denken so zu sagen das
wäre natürlich schön weil dann sind sie
ja dabei dann beschäftigen sie sich
damit dann suchen sie die antwort auf
das ungleichgewicht vom anfang
wie kann man das machen diese positive
valencia zu stellen
da gibt es sind sehr sehr hilfreich
positive emotionen mehr
also irgendwie es zu schaffen die
selbstbestimmung bedürfnisse aus
befriedigen dazu die selbstbestimmung
theorie von dc und ryan die besagt dass
es im prinzip drei bedürfnisse gibt wenn
mal die grundbedürfnisse befriedigt sind
die sogenannten selbstbestimmung
bedürfnisse menschen möchten sich als
autonom erleben als kompetent und als
sozial eingebunden autonom
es ist ganz klar und ihr könnt euch
wahrscheinlich alle vorstellen das macht
nicht spaß man neben einem einer steht
und er sagt und jetzt machst du das und
dann machst du darf sondern mache
sondern machst du dass sie extrem
übertriebene form aber das macht ja eben
auch arbeitsplätze die so sehr straff
durchstrukturierten fließbandarbeit usw
zu sehr großen herausforderungen oder
belastungen dann letztlich auch für die
jeweiligen menschen also wir haben
bedürfnis nach autonomie wir möchten
auch selbstbestimmt sein bedürfnis nach
kompetenz nichts ist so frustrierend wie
wenn ich ständig scheitere
also wir nehmen jeder mal scheitern in
kauf in der regel je nachdem wie groß
und resilienz ist mehr oder weniger aber
wir wenn wir immer nur scheitern werden
irgendwann aufgeben
das ist klar es wäre ja auch unsinnig
dann immer noch weiterzumachen
insofern bedürfnis nach kompetenz und
trittins bedürfnisses das bedürfnis nach
der sozialen eingebundenheit und da
kommen glaube ich noch mal eure methoden
diese richtung humorvoll gehen vorher ja
auch mal angesprochen worden vielleicht
interaktiv wir sind herren tiere als
menschen und es ist meistens ziemlich
unangenehm wenn wir in einer richtig
großen gruppe sind und niemanden kennen
ich weiß nicht so genau was der rechts
und links und so von mir hält und ob ich
was sagen kann oder nicht und ob mit der
dozent oder die dozenten gleichauf rest
völlig flapsig und übertrieben
formuliert aber so in diese richtung
geht und in diesem sinne könnte man
natürlich jetzt sagen wir haben dann
positiven emotionen wenn diese drei
selbstbestimmung bedürfnisse
gewissermaßen befriedigt werden und da
kommen auch wieder sagen dass es daneben
der positive aufforderungscharakter da
diese positive valent wir können also
schauen dass wir unsere regionen in
diesem lebensraum von levin so gestalten
dass die studierenden immer mal wieder
auch das gefühl haben ich kann nicht
auch autonom bewegen
in dieser lehrveranstaltung geht nur bis
zu einem gewissen grad ohne frage ja es
kann selbst der vorstand mit nur 16 oder
20 studieren kann nicht jeder tun was er
will
funktioniert nicht aber wir können ihnen
die möglichkeiten geben wie referats
themen selber wählen oder mal in ob sie
alleine oder zu zweit arbeiten sollen in
irgend einer aktivierenden phase dass
man so auswahlmöglichkeiten schafft ja
wo es halt geht
wir sollten schauen natürlich dass wir
das niveau anpassen dass sie das gefühl
haben oder immer wieder auch dieses
erlebnis haben kompetenz zu erleben das
erleben sie auch wenig wenn sie nur
zuhören müssen
das erleben sie dann wenn sie sich durch
geprägt wissen haben durch 110 a und es
geschafft haben und dann liegt da ja
dann haben sie dieses erlebnis solange
ich da vorne nur stehe und rede werden
die denken höre alles nett aber es
bringt keine große emotionale regung und
die soziale eingebundenheit die müssen
da auch fördern natürlich einerseits
durch interaktion zwischen uns und den
studentinnen und studenten und auf der
anderen seite zwischen ihnen
ich glaube jemand von euch hatte vorher
auch gesagt dass wenn die manchmal
untereinander mehr reden und und
interagieren wird auch das verhältnis
dann zu den dozenten dozenten besser und
dass es eben auch ganz ganz wichtig geht
in kleineren gruppen selbstverständlich
besser aber wir können auch in großen
gruppen an angebote machen für
interaktionen eben auch dort mal
versuchen mit ihnen ins gespräch zu
kommen sie dort auch mal zu aktivieren
und in den hörsaal reinlaufen einfach
shuttle gewisse nähe tut sich da oder
hilft an der stelle
gut dass hamburg das heißt wenn wir das
geschafft haben haben wir die
aufmerksamkeit geweckt und haben jetzt
quasi sicher gestellt dass sie dabei
bleiben
bisher haben wir aber eigentlich nur die
situation jetzt sie fühlen sich jetzt
wohl sie sind dabei sie haben die
aufmerksamkeit auf uns gerichtet und sie
fühlen sich wohl aber sollen sie ja
bitte auch noch lernen
wir haben also im prinzip diesen aspekt
erledigt aber jetzt müssen sie lernen
vaters lehren daraus bis hierhin wir
sollten schauen dass wir ziele und
relevanz verdeutlichen damit sie
überhaupt wissen in diesem lebensraum
quasi buch geht es eigentlich überhaupt
hin
deswegen machen wir ja mittlerweile auch
ganz vieles gehört
schon fast ein bisschen zum state of the
art ziele eben zu formulieren zu
beginnen und dann sollten wir schauen
dass wir eben diese drei selbst führte
stimmungs bedürfnisse immer in einem
gewissen maße eben auch realisieren
umsätzen berücksichtigen
wie wird nun gelernt
man kann den lernprozess als ein prozess
beschreiben mit der mit fünf prozess zu
prozessen gewissermaßen erfolgt und die
idee dahinter also erstes mal das kommt
tatsächlich aus der forschung das sind
alles teilprozesse die man so aus der
lehr lernforschung der letzten vierzig
fünfzig jahre herleiten kann und man
kann jetzt natürlich sagen okay wenn es
diese fünf prozesse des lernens gibt es
ist ja wunderbar wir können hingehen als
lehrende nach und sagen wir unterstützen
jeden dieser einzelnen zur prozesse des
lernens dann müsste es ja eigentlich
ganz gut funktionieren den ersten den
händler schon
der hat nämlich eben genau damit zu tun
dass menschen dann lernt man
aufmerksamkeit zuwendung stattgefunden
hat den hammer also im prinzip schon
geklärt
das ungleichgewicht des ausgelöst was
passiert bei menschen wenn das
ungleichgewicht ausgelöst wird wir
fangen automatisch an zu handeln uns
damit zu beschäftigen nachzudenken zu
reflektieren wie kann das sein
finde ich eine antwort auf diese frage
dann wenn wir nicht zu keiner antwort
kommen die uns befriedigt dann suchen
wir die umwelt danach ab und suchen nach
antworten
extern das heißt es kann zum beispiel
wenn wir jetzt im moment mal nur auf
einen lernprozess schauen der quasi so
impliziten nebenbei erfolg kann es an
der stelle sein dass ich im gespräch wo
der andere was sagt und ich denke so
hell dann sage ich besten das gemeint
das wäre eine suche oder wir lesen
irgendwas und denken so interessant wie
kann das sein
was machen wir dann dann googeln wird
halt mal schnell machen wir ja heute
mittlerweile alle ständig und es kann so
weit gehen dass man forschungsprojekt
anstoßen weil wir eine frage haben ja
die unser ungleichgewicht ausgelöst hat
um die wollen wir beantworten dann gehen
wir auf die suche durch richtige
forschung
wir suchen solange bis es uns gelingt
hier zu einer integration zu kommen
in dem sinne dass dass wir das was wir
gefunden haben jetzt in unser
bestehendes wissen integrieren können
und dadurch unser gleichgewicht wieder
hergestellt wird an der stelle spricht
man von so genannten klick auf
compression ja in dem moment habe ich
auch das gefühl heureka jetzt habe ich
es verstanden
es kann gut sein dass wir diese zwei
prozesse mehrmals oder so interagieren
durchlaufen wir suchen wir müssen
schauen passte dann sagt man ihn noch
nicht also muss ich weiter suchen dann
versuchen wir wieder zu integrieren und
in dem moment wo es passt haben wir
jetzt sozusagen diesen prozess
abgeschlossen integration integriert
will sagen ich habe es verstanden
man würde an der stelle aber noch nicht
sagen dass gelernt wurde
es ist nur die vorstufe von lern es ist
das was die voraussetzung ist die
information wurde gewissermaßen
verarbeitet aber dauerhaftes noch nicht
ja wenn ihr noch mal und mein bild von
vorher denken mit diesen verbindungen es
ist noch so eine schmale verbindung
wahrscheinlich eine dünne was nämlich
dazu kommen muss sagt die forschung
eindeutig es muss im prinzip elaboriert
werden geübt werden menschen müssen sich
mit dem was es sich längerfristig
behalten möchten was längerfristig zur
veränderung von handlungs potenzial von
wissen führen soll
müssen sie sich länger auseinandersetzen
tiefe auseinandersetzen aus einer
zweiten perspektive drauf gucken dritte
perspektive einnehmen
nicht nur einmal lernen wie der
schreibprozess funktioniert sondern
einmal schreiben zweimal schreiben
dreimal und so weiter ja und wirklich
viel und auch nicht nur eins sondern
viele szenarien bauen dann geht es
langsam sozusagen in fleisch und blut
über das sind also gewissermaßen diese
fünf so prozesse die der reihe nach im
prinzip mehr oder weniger kann man sagen
so beschrieben sind und der in dieser
reihe nach eben auch erfolgen
und das können wir uns noch mal zusammen
bringen letztlich mit dem was ich vorher
gesagt habe oder was wir vorher uns
angeschaut haben dass es dazu aber eben
auch noch diese positive umgebung bedarf
es funktioniert dann eben besser ja eben
nicht in der angstbesetzten situation
sondern dann wenn es einfach auch noch
ist dabei zu sein wenn die regionen
positiven aufforderungscharakter haben
positiv valent sind ich mich autonom
fühlen kann immer mal wieder
erfolgserlebnisse habe sozial
eingebunden bin was hat es für
konsequenten jetzt für das lehren und da
möchte ich euch gerne das kombi modell
vorstellen kombi steht für model auf
model based instruction und deshalb 20
weil es jetzt gerade überarbeitet wurde
es ist das erste mal 2007 88 publiziert
worden
da hat sich das im prinzip nur auf diese
fünf prozesse des lernens bezogen als
sie noch ein sehr starker fokus fast
ausschließlich auf die kognition und
durch die neuere forschung muss man
einfach sagen da hat man vielleicht auch
früher zu lange eigentlich sehr stark
immer nur wert gelegt auf das kognitive
man muss es motivation ahlers emotionale
sehr viel mehr mit berücksichtigen
deswegen bombe 200 das soll eben auch
noch in dieser positiven umgebung
stattfinden und das hilft uns jetzt im
prinzip zu sagen okay so funktioniert
lernen wunderbar und wir müssen also
schauen wir in der lehrveranstaltung
wollen im rahmen unserer live anschauen
was die studierenden lernen muss jede
lehrveranstaltung das sicherstellen
es muss auf der einen seite diese
positive umgebung schaffen es muss
sicher stellen dass für aufmerksamkeit
geweckt wird das vermissen aktiviert
wird das informationen gesucht
beziehungsweise gegeben werden dass
integriert wird und dann irgendwie auch
noch elabo ration und üben und daraus
ergibt sich jetzt dieses monkey 2.0
modell
ihr seht hier in blau diese fünf so
prozesse und da hat sich jetzt noch eine
reingeschoben hier in rosa abgebildet
das ist nämlich der den wir aus der lern
aus der motivation special ogi
abgeleitet haben nämlich zu sagen
menschen bleiben dann auch dabei wenn es
mal nicht so positiv ist an die ziele
stark genug sind und deswegen ist ein
vorschlag dieses modells im prinzip zu
sagen hier können wir die studierenden
dann auch über ziele und deren relevanz
informieren
klar könnten wir es an anfang stellen
wir können noch sagen heute sind unsere
ziele folgende ist aber unter umständen
möglicherweise relativ
trocken ja und ein bisschen so dröge
wenn es tolle viele sind wecken wir
damit aufmerksamkeit dann deckt sich das
gewissermaßen sofort wenn es das jetzt
er nicht ist und wenn es mir vielleicht
auch nicht gelingt ist so zu formulieren
dass es für die studierenden wirklich
gleich von anfang an attraktiv ist dann
starte ich besser mit irgendetwas was
vor mixen oder was aufmerksamkeit weckt
und sagen ihnen danach und jetzt erkläre
ich euch wie das funktioniert also um
das beispiel aus der medizin vorher
wieder noch einmal aufzunehmen
jetzt haben wir gesagt also das ist mir
passiert da am samstagabend notaufnahme
ich junge ärztin usw
aber keine angst heute in dieser
veranstaltung lernt ja wie er damit
umgeht dass es euch nicht passiert booms
haben wir hier ein ziel und die relevanz
dürfte eigentlich auch klar sein
ja also wenn wir das schaffen wäre
natürlich prima so und dann können die
anderen schritte im prinzip
hinterherkommen wir geben dann
möglicherweise informationen die sie
eben brauchen um ihre auf um ihr
gleichgewicht wieder herzustellen
das heißt beispiel medizin jetzt wird
irgendwie die differentialdiagnose
dargestellt dessen was jetzt dieser
patient der da in die notaufnahme an
diesem samstagabend kam haben könnte
hier könnte also der vortrag stattfinden
hier könnte ich auch mit texten arbeiten
studieren sagen hier diesen text lesen
diesen text bearbeiten nach antworten
suchen auf das was hier vorne das auf
märkte aufmerksamkeit ausgelöst hat und
dann muss ich ihnen aber immer auch die
möglichkeit geben also ihre reflexion
symbole geben das ist dann der
sachverhalt die methoden angeguckt haben
vor allem in richtung inhaltsbezogen hat
er es genannt inhalts nahm genau also
die die unterhalb vom strich standen
weil hier geht es jetzt darum
tatsächlich sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen mit dem was man
davor gehört hat was man davor gelesen
hat was in einem video gezeigt wurde was
in dem podcast präsentiert worden sein
kann ganz unterschiedlich und dann kommt
noch der letzte schritt laborieren und
üben lassen wäre natürlich auch noch
schön wenn ich ehrlich sein da haben wir
manchmal eine lehrveranstaltung direkt
also inter press land selbst dazu nicht
mehr wirklich die zeit dass es dann das
was in die anderen elf tage 100% arbeit
gesteckt werden kann zb ich kann auch
die anderen prozesse auslagern ja
klassischerweise geisteswissenschaften
lagern auf diesen prozess eigentlich
außen saniert nächste heim und ihr kommt
schon mit dem gelesenen das solltet ihr
schon haben schon gemacht haben und wir
fokussieren dann ganz gewaltig auf diese
reflexion nämlich diesen austausch
darüber was hast du gemacht das habe ich
gemacht wie konnte man es noch sehen
die klassische vorlesung hatten fokus
hier drauf sie präsentiert vor allem
wissen heißt aber eben auch nicht nur
wissen zu präsentieren wäre
unvollständig weil wir damit ja den
nicht den ganzen prozess abbilden
sondern sollte eben auch das davor
kommen und es sollte mindestens kurse
aktivierende mit momente letztlich geben
in diesem prozess mindestens mal so eine
denkpause oder vielleicht eine kurze
murmel phase bass krupp in quiz super
experte was vielleicht nicht so viel
zeit braucht so also das ja ich hätte es
vorher schon anklicken können dass es
herr geheiratet wird es also das wird
quasi jetzt aus der motivation
psychologie dazu kommt und jetzt kommen
wir müssen wir natürlich auch noch dran
denken sozial einzubinden autonomie zu
sichern und kompetenzen zu ermöglichen
und damit habt ihr im prinzip einen
vorschlag für eine modell mehr oder
weniger zu sagen das ist die
grundlegende strukturierung von der
lehrveranstaltung wobei wie gesagt
einzelne aspekte davon ausgelagert
werden können jederzeit typischerweise
findet in lehrveranstaltungen auf dass
hier auch wiederholen statt
ich wecke nicht mehrmals aufmerksamkeit
immer wieder mit neuen aspekten sondern
die aufmerksamkeit weg ich dann
vielleicht durch durch ebenso humorvolle
methode
durch diesen wechsel nicht die ganze
zeit nur monokultur sondern daneben auch
mal glückstopf zwischen rhein und dann
trage ich wieder vor und dann kommt noch
das super experten hinterher
und damit zur frage monokultur oder
feuerwerk wir brauchen eigentlich so
viele lehrmethoden dass eben dieser
lernprozess in der form unterstützt wird
dann passts und für jede dieser
bausteine in diesem modell gibt es im
prinzip eben auch unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten die wir haben und man
könnte im prinzip sagen okay ich brauche
eine mitte oder um aufmerksamkeit zu
wecken
ich brauche eine um vorwissen zu
aktivieren gut dann präsentiere ich im
prinzip nur schnell die ziele und die
relevant ist zeitlich auch sehr sehr
wenig dann brauche ich eine methode um
zu informieren ich brauche eine methode
mindestens um reflexion impuls zu geben
und sollte vielleicht auch noch übungs
gelegenheiten schaffen falls ich sie
nicht aber wenn selbst dann wenn ich sie
im selbststudium verleger brauche ich ja
auch dort eine anregung eine anleitung
das wäre sozusagen die idee monokultur
kann es also eigentlich nicht sein weil
wir würden dann sagen wir machen eben
nur informieren und da bieten das sind
so diese klassischen eigentlich manchmal
auch ziemlich langweiligen vorlesung zum
beispiel aber auch ich habe es selber in
meinem eigenen germanistik studium
kennengelernt dieses ewige wir haben
lektüre gelesen und dann reden wir halt
mal drüber aber völlig ziellos und
planlos du hast vorher glaube ich gesagt
das verläuft sich dann irgendwie so dass
der fahrer zum ankommt dann auch vom
hundertsten ins tausendste das ist
genauso eine mono methode auch wenn die
natürlich theoretisch aktivierender ist
als eine vorlesung aber auch das reicht
eigentlich eben nicht aus sondern es
braucht irgendwie mehrere aber nicht im
sinne von zwei minuten das 2 3 minuten
das grob gesprochen könnte man sagen
hier werden für den einstieg irgendwie
ungefähr zehn prozent der
lehrveranstaltung zeit die wir zur
verfügung haben und dann haben wir im
seminar den fokus hier drauf in der
vorlesung den fokus hier drauf aber es
gibt dann immer wieder den wechsel
ich glaube die kollegin vom dass nicht
du sondern seine kollegin hatte glaube
ich gesagt ein kollege macht manchmal so
eine phase wo er dann schreibaufgaben
nach 45 minuten mal kurz gibt schreibt
mal auf was wir mitnehmen
typisch für vorlesungen
ich würde von der forschung her sagen
lieber nicht nach 45 minuten lieber nach
circa 20 bis 30 minuten
aber genau das ist zum beispiel so was
was ich in der vorlesung eben machen
könnte ja das ist recht brandneu was ich
euch hier präsentiert habe deswegen
bisschen werbung das ist gerade
erschienen herausgegeben von heinz
bachmann dieses dieses buch ist angles
in higher education da ist eben dieses
modell etwas genauer beschrieben und das
wird demnächst erscheinen wir haben
gerade die letzte korrektur fahne gehabt
in der reihe von der sabine brendel
kompetenzorientierte lehren
ich möchte aber gerne an der stelle
nicht so stehen lassen sondern euch im
prinzip jetzt auch bevor wir direkt
natürlich auch eine fragerunde eingehen
einfach mal aktivieren und man fragen
was er denn jetzt für methoden
eigentlich kennt für die
unterschiedlichen phasen
wir haben vor ort und methoden kennen
gelernt wir können sie ja im prinzip
jetzt ein bisschen wie zu ordnen und ich
hab dafür für euch ein patriot
eingerichtet und alle diejenigen die
jetzt ein internetzugang haben kann mit
dem handy sein kann mit einem ipad sein
kann mit einem laptop sein
ihr dürft euch mal unter diesem link
hier oder auch mit dem qr code einfach
da einloggen ich weiß nicht die
organisatoren vielleicht kann ich euch
einfach die präsentation noch schicken
dann habt ihr auch den link dann im
prinzip immer direkt dazu noch mal klar
jeder der den link hat kann es auch
verändern kann also auch was ergänzen
das ist bei diesem modell einfach so und
ihr seht jetzt im prinzip also viele
viele möglichkeiten die jeweils
innerhalb dieser spalten mehr oder
weniger eben die gleiche funktion
erfüllen so dass die gewissermaßen auch
gegeneinander austauschbar sind
ja ich kann mich entscheidend text lesen
lassen wenn ich möchte dass die lesen
oder ich kann sagen ich halte einen
vortrag und ich sag habe ich schneller
systematisch zusammengefasst als denen
300 text zeiten dafür zu geben
ja
in diesem sinne gehe ich ganz kurz auf
meine präsentation zurück aber auch nur
ganz kurz denn da kommt euch nicht mehr
viel sondern ihr seid herzlich
eingeladen fragen zu stellen wenn ihr
wollt
sabrina hat das vorher sogar schon
gesagt ideen für methoden methoden
schatzkiste auf meiner webseite
vielleicht auch für euch interessant ist
gibt zahlreiche solcher online methoden
ich glaub sibylle hatte vorher auch
gesagt du weißt auch eine ich habe dort
ganz viele verlinkt also die dies frei
im netz quasi gibt und ich finde ein und
da stelle ich die da immer also verlinke
sie dort quasi immer dass es eine
möglichkeit und falls ihr lust habt auch
weiterhin irgendwie euch über
hochschuldidaktik auszutauschen und
nicht eine aversion hat gegen facebook
die ich auch verstehen kann dann
herzliche einladung zur
hochschuldidaktik facebook gruppe die
jetzt so langsam in gang kommt und was
ich sehr spannend findet also die haben
jetzt gerade diskutiert wie wichtig ist
humor in der lehre eigentlich zum
beispiel was mache ich mit vielen
motivierten studentinnen und studenten
also ist spannend ist eine geschlossene
gruppe
das heißt ist dann auch nicht nach außen
primär mal sichtbar was facebook danach
damit macht wissen wir alle nicht klar
vielen dank